Serbia's president has called on ethnic
Serb demonstrators in Northern Kosovo to
remain peaceful after days of tension in
the region Alexander vouchic was
speaking at the European political
community meeting in Moldova I'm always
very reluctant to be too optimistic
and but
I guarantee one thing
survey will do its best and its utmost
to de-escalate the situation which means
that well
[Music]
attempt to persuade serves to protest
calmly and peacefully
we're opposition to the election of
ethnic Albanian Mayors in Northern
crossover has intensified since they
took office last weekend following votes
largely boycotted by the ethnic Serb
population NATO has boosted its 4 000
strong mission in the region after
dozens of peacekeepers and protesters
were hurt in confrontations on Monday
acid beg is live for us in Northern
Kosovo and as it just gives an idea of
what's happening there and what the
mood's like
well generally the mood here has been
calm we have NATO forces behind me
NATO's Kosovo Force known as K4
protecting the municipality building the
erected barriers and barbed wire and
they have their military vehicles around
this building now that's after
protesters try to take over those
buildings last weekend early this week
in fact but the mood generally has been
calm here people here at thick serbs
here have been playing uh nationalist
music chanting nationalistic slogans and
raving the Serbia Flag but it hasn't
been violent unlike other places that
we've seen for example as avenge which
is south of here now police say on
Wednesday there police vehicles were
attacked one police officer was injured
and some journalists were also attacked
along with their vehicles being
vandalized but the mood there has been
tense but here so far it's very calm and
when you speak to people here they just
want to voice their opposition to those
ethnic Albanian Mayors taking office but
not just that generally they don't want
any Kosovo police in the region
[Music]
so I said so what happens next
but people have been talking about
de-escalation at least the politicians
have but nothing has really emerged now
uh prime minister Alvin Gordy has
suggested early elections uh for those
mayoral elections but the problem with
that is that it doesn't get to the root
cause many ethnic serves boycotted those
elections it turned out was less than
three and a half percent and many serbs
in the north don't recognize uh Customs
institutions they they believe that the
North in fact all of Kosovo is a part of
Serbia in fact here the Serbian Serbia
Flag is flown everywhere and when you
speak to people they say this is a part
of Serbia now the Kosovo president
president usmani has said that their
external actors seeking to destabilize
the country and he said that the real
threat lies in Serbia is not recognizing
Kosovo the state of Kosovo but the
president of Serbia has said that those
alleged mayors that she calls them
shouldn't take office but again that
doesn't get to the root cause and that
is that the ethnic serbs do not
recognize is Kosovo do not recognize the
institutions and they feel that not only
the northern regions but all of
customers should be a part of Serbia and
that's the root cause so they are
talking about de-escalation and even if
those Mayors don't take office even if
they are early elections and even if the
police leave these facilities it doesn't
really mean that the tensions will
reduce uh in terms of those root causes
indeed I said we'll leave it there
thanks very much I said big reporting